To reduce the time it takes
to send data, a lot of websites
compress their assets with gzip
or other compression algorithms
that work on the web.
The HT [INAUDIBLE]
boilerplate project
uses the gzip compression.
Check below for more
information about this.
Compression of
the data is great,
but the request and
response headers are still
being sent uncompressed.
When you think about it, that
doesn't make a lot of sense.
They are plain text, which
makes them highly compressible.
Also, they repeat a
lot across requests.
The host header's always the
same, the cookies are the same,
and so are some other headers.
In Google's research paper, they
state that on average headers
take up about 800 bytes.
Let's look at the potential
savings we could have.
If a site made 100 requests,
roughly 80 kilobytes of data
would be taken up by the
headers, and most of that
would be redundant.
We'd save a lot of space if
we could compress the headers.
Unfortunately, we can't
do that with HTTP1,
but with HTTP2, we can.